Transcriber: Yasmeen Elsayed
المدقّق: MOSAAB MOHAMED  ZEINELABDIN  MOHAMED ELMAHDI
اشكر مدرسة الخليج الوطني على
تقديمها الفرصة الجميلة هذه
واتاحة الفرصة لي اني أقدم كلام مفيد
للفئات السنية المختلفة
معنى الثقة بالنفس من منظوري
وحط تحت كلمة منظوري ثلاثة
خطوط أو أربعة، عزيزي المشاهد، براحتك
معنى الثقة بالنفس بالنسبة
لي من منظوري أنا أشوف
إنها مفتاح يستخدمه أي طفل أو أي إنسان كان
عشان يكسر أي حاجز أو يفتح باب هذا الحاجز
الذي هو يستعصى عليه أو صعب عليه تجاوزه
الثقة بالنفس هي عبارة عن مفتاح نستخدمه نحن
نتجاوز فيها أشياء صعبة في حياتنا
أو حواجز صعبة ما نقدر نتخطاها
أهمية الثقة بالنفس للفئات العمرية الصغيرة
ونحن نتكلم عن نحن لما كنا صغار
أو بشكل عام من خمس سنين
لاثني عشر سنوات يعني نحن
عندنا أشياء أو مشاكل
أو أشياء نخاف نتخطاها مثلا
نفرض أنا بعطي نفسي على سبيل المثال
بتكلم على نفسي أنا كنت انسان
استحي بشكل كبير جدا
كنت استحالة اني اقف قدام كاميرا
أو قدام ناس واتكلم
ولكن لما وثقت في نفسي
ولقيت المفتاح هذا قدرت اتخطى الحاجز
وصرت فعلا ما اخاف من أي كلمة أو
أي شي وصرت اتكلم قدام أي حد ما عندي مشكلة
دراسة تربوية واجتماعية عن مؤشرات
وحالات انعدام الثقة
وأسباب انعدام الثقة لدى الأطفال
والفئات السنية الصغيرة
وتقول الدراسة أن مقصد التعليم الأسمى وغاية
الرعاية الأسرية الاثنين تقف في هدف واحد
وتتمثل هذه الدراسة في تعزيز قدرات الطفل
وتمكينه من قيادة حياة مستقبلية مستقلة
بحيث انه يقدر يفيد المجتمع
وأهله بكل النواحي والطلبة
وعشان يقدر الطفل يحدد
هذه الأهداف أو هذه الإنجازات
نحن نحتاج إننا نعزز في مفتاح معين أو نوفر
له مفتاح معين واللي هو  مفتاح الثقة بالنفس
واللي هو أحد أهم المفاتيح اللي يحتاجها
في حياته كطفل صغير
بما أن الثقة بالنفس لهذه الدرجة
مهمة لنا نحن كأطفال وكبار
فالسؤال ممكن نقدر نطور
الثقة بالنفس نحن كأشخاص عاديين
عندنا هوايات عديدة جدا أو رياضات
نحن نلعبها تسلي وقتنا أيا كانت
السؤال كيف ممكن نقدر
نطور من هذه الرياضة؟
الموضوع بسيط بالتدريب. بالتمرين. نفس الشيء
في الثقة بالنفس بالتدريب والتمرين
تقدر تطور من الثقة بالنفس بنفسك
حدد أنت شو مشكلتك
أو شو اللي انت ما عندك ثقة بيه
فلنفترض أنك واحد تستحي
حاول تشوف شو الاساليب اللي تقدر
تطورها او تقدر تشتغل عليها
عشان تطور هذا الشيء وتكسر هذا الحاجز
دائما خليك إيجابي خليك بعيد عن أي شيء سلبي
مهما صار شيء سلبي حاول إنك تشوفه
من الطرف الايجابي مهما كان سلبي بشكل كبير
حاول إنك تحط أهداف لنفسك
من اليوم من فترة لفترة
فلنفرض من أول ثلاثة أشهر من السنة
بعدين الثلاثة أشهر القادمة وهكذا
حاول أنك تحط أهدافك المقدمة
تشوف انك انت راح  تطور فيها
نفسك بشكل كبير جدا جدا جدا
بهذه الطريقة راح تشوف الثقة بالنفس
فثقتك في نفسك راح تزداد
حبة حبة. خطوة خطوة
وفي الأخير راح تشوف أنك مطور نفسك من كل
النواحي ليس فقط الناحية الي كنت ضعيف فيها
انت كإنسان هدفك إنك تكون إنسان ناجح
أو توصل لمرحلة معينة يسموك فيها
إنسان ناجح في دربك هذا
ودربك هذا أو طريقك هذا كله
راح تشوف كلام سلبي
من يمينك يسارك فوقك تحتك تسمع كلام سلبي
لاكن السؤال كيف نحول الكلام السلبي هذا
لطاقة نتغذى عليها ونحولها لسبب
من أسباب نجاحنا
حتى نصعد الجبل اللي هو جبل النجاح هذا
تعال ناخذ الكلام السلبي
وتحاول تلعب فيه بطريقة معينة
وتحوله وتشوفه بطريقة معينة
أن تشوف هذا الكلام إيجابي
لهذا السبب أنا عشان
أوصل لهدف من أهدافي أنا
فلنفرض لسبيل المثال أنا بتكلم عن نفسي أنا
والاشياء اللي مررت بها
أنا كبدايتي يمكن أول ثلاث أربع سنوات
بقيت أشوف فقط كلام سلبي
انت ما راح توصل. ما راح تنجح
مكانك مش هنا، غير مكانك، أنت ما راح
تنجح ولكن اللي سويته أنا
أنا عندي قاعدة في حياتي
أني أخذ الكلام السلبي أو اللي
يحطمني وأوريه أن ذلك
سبب من الأسباب أن أنا اثبتله أنه غلط
لما أنت تحاول أنك تثبت
لصاحب الكلام أن هو غلط
صدقني أنت هكذا إنسان ناجح
لأن كلما زاد الكلام السلبي عليك
بهذه الطريقة طاقتك تزداد
حاول إنك ما تتأثر بالكلام السلبي.
الكلام السلبي كلما تأثرت بيه
راح تغرق أكثر وأكثر
وصدقني لو وصلت للقاع
استحالة تصل للقمة مرة ثانية
خذ الكلام السلبي هذا وحوله لكلام إيجابي
عشان توصل للقمة اللي انت ناوي توصلها
بعد فترة من التدريب أو التمارين التي
تكلمنا عنها اللي طابقتها وسويتها
راح تكتشف أن المفتاح بدأ يوضع وين مكانة
مفتاح الثقة بالنفس بدأ يوضع مكانه
ولما يكون المفتاح هذا بيدك
بعمرك ما راح تخسر ثقتك في نفسك